[Music]
hello Facebook Lee anti-glare here
joined with a familiar face the one and
only Chad Michael Murray and he is
starring in a brand new show on CMT
called Sun Records it premieres next
Thursday at 10:00 p.m. and you guys are
going to fall in love with it Chad thank
you so much for coming in today thanks
for having me this show I just watched
the first episode this morning is so
unique there's nothing else like it on
TV right now
with bringing sexy back from the city
what can I say it was such a labor of
love every single person just committed
so much you know there's not a weak link
and I'm just really excited to see this
side of the Sun Records story told you
know everybody knows the icon Jerry Lee
Lewis the Elvis to Johnny Cash but to
now see it kind of through Sam's eyes
he's the man that found all of this the
man that started rock and roll that's
kind of the man behind the curtain that
no one knows it's it's gonna be an
incredibly exciting time I'm excited to
see how people respond I think when you
step on it was set the the set design
and the costumes really does have to
work for you you really time travel back
and you're in the air and you feel a
part of the world but for me the best
part is the music you know getting to
sit and record Darius Rucker who comes
in he's playing Johnny Bragg on the show
one of the prisoners and record him what
an opportunity what a moment yeah to
work with icons and unbelievably
talented human beings and musicians it
was exciting it is interesting because
you know Netflix did bring back another
show that you were part of Gilmore Girls
and I was watching it and they aren't
Chilton and then they make a reference
to Tristan Dougray and I look and it is
not you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what
happened is I'm so curious to know did
they reach out you know um yeah I mean I
heard I wasn't available at the time
mm-hmm I'm pretty positive I was having
a baby yes uh my first child and so it
just it just did not work into the what
in a moment and so I know that the
somebody went out and was Tristan but uh
it wouldn't mean one name I hear strong
work strong work good job man I mean
coming from you that's nice coming from
a fan who knows the real Tristan Dougray
I wouldn't agree but that's know you and
I appreciate they do but you know the
Tristan secret was be that guy that
every girl wants to be next to but just
isn't sure they should that was really
that I heard he did it with
[Music]
you